spider-man this is mr. Beck here
Mysterio clam stock chose we need an
Avenger
mr. stark trusted me I'm not gonna let
him down let's go save the world
spider-man
I've got this I have a planet first for
this class track I want to do something
that's not on the itinerary
second I'm gonna tell him Jake how I
feel all right
mmm spider-man no of course it was three
I kind of want to do something fun
don't do any of that why because we're
gonna be bachelors in Europe and
Europeans love Americans Billy
spider-man far from home starts July 2nd
in IMAX so it has the trip going always
that guy you were with
there's a new guy
good thing I packed your suit huh yeah
got gifts Parker are you going to step
up or not let's go save the world
spider-man
I'm gonna get so many followers
[Music]
spider-man far from home Nick Fury just
hijacked our summer vacation no miss not
yet radio that darks hey we're just
talking about the trip the universe is
in chaos
suit up spider-man I didn't think I was
gonna have to save the world - son what
do you want Peter
I want to go back on my trip the girl
who I really like and tell her how I
feel
I'm Jay I am spider-man what I mean it's
kind of obvious
so you know - I've known first but it's
not a competition this film is not yet
rated gonna be the Next Iron Man well no
I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs the world needs the next Iron
Man I'm just a friendly neighborhood
spider-man thank you for having me gifts
Parker
world needs that I think Nick Fury just
hijacked their vacation spider-man for
from
you